CARTER: If you're working on
Kubernetes in a production
environment, especially on
a larger project or team,
you've probably run
into namespaces.
We haven't talked
about them before,
but today, we change that.
Hello, Caslyn.
Hello, Caslyn?
Hmm, Caslyn isn't in this room.
Maybe I'll go into another one.
Hello, Caslyn?
CASLYN: Oh, hi, Carter.
What are you doing here?
CARTER: I came to talk
to you about namespaces,
but I don't think I
could reach you before.
CASLYN: That's kind
of ironic, actually.
Namespaces are a tool to keep
Kubernetes objects separated,
as well.
If you're in the
wrong space, you
won't be able to communicate
with your objects.
CARTER: I could see
that being useful.
Kind of like how containers
allow multiple applications
to share one operating
system, namespaces
allow multiple Kubernetes
objects to share one cluster.
CASLYN: Right, imagining it
as a sort of virtual cluster
makes a lot of sense, because
a namespace groups and isolates
Kubernetes objects across nodes.
And it's not quite as strict
as container isolation,
because it's still possible to
access Kubernetes objects that
are in other namespaces.
CARTER: That's good to know.
So a namespace is
a virtual cluster
that's used to make it easier
for large teams to work.
I've seen these before.
I was working on a project where
the test and production objects
were in separate namespaces.
CASLYN: Sure, I've seen that.
Another benefit of
namespaces comes in
with setting permissions.
CARTER: Oh, yeah, I remember.
The admin set it up so that
only certain people could
push a build to
production, but anyone
could push a build to test.
CASLYN: They would
have done that using
Kubernetes role-based
access controls, or RBAC.
Using RBAC, an administrator
can give each user
a role, which sets
their permissions
inside a specific namespace.
CARTER: That makes sense.
So the people on
my team must have
had roles that gave
them access to test,
but only a few
people had roles that
gave them access to production.
CASLYN: Right.
Let's talk more about how to set
up the namespaces themselves.
We can cover RBAC, or
role-based access controls,
in a future episode.
CARTER: Sounds good to me.
So how do I get started
using namespaces?
CASLYN: Technically,
you already are.
Kubernetes starts with
four initial namespaces.
You can check them out with the
kubectl get namespace command.
CARTER: According to
the docs, kube-system
is for objects created
by the Kubernetes system.
kube-public is mostly reserved
for cluster usage in case
some resources should be
visible and readable publicly
throughout the whole cluster.
kube-node-lease is for the
lease objects associated
with each node, which
improves the performance
of the node heartbeats
as a cluster scales.
And the default
namespace is for objects
with no other namespace.
It's like one of those bottom
drawers in the kitchen--
just throw anything in there.
CASLYN: You can get more info
about any of these namespaces
using the kubectl get
and describe commands.
For instance, you'll see
that describing the default
namespace returns
something like this.
Note that these details
show both resource quota,
if present, as well as
resource limit ranges.
CARTER: Resource quotas
and resource limits?
CASLYN: Resource quota tracks
aggregate usage of resources
in the namespace and
allows cluster operators
to define hard
resource usage limits
that a namespace may consume.
A limit range defines minimum
and maximum constraints
on the amount of resources
a single entity can
consume in a namespace.
CARTER: That seems
useful if I need
to make sure resource usage is
staying within certain bounds.
CASLYN: Yep, resource
quotas and limits
are an important tool
for administrators.
CARTER: Since namespaces
are Kubernetes objects,
I bet I can interact with
them using the kubectl create
and delete commands.
CASLYN: Yes.
One thing that's
a little different
is that since namespaces hold
other Kubernetes objects,
if you want to get, create,
delete, or otherwise
operate on objects
in a namespace,
you must specify that with
the --namespaces flag.
CARTER: It seems like
a lot of extra typing,
but I guess the shorthand
-n isn't all that bad.
CASLYN: We can actually shorten
"deployment" here to "deploy,"
too.
There are a lot of
convenient shorthand versions
of commands in Kubernetes.
CARTER: That is
convenient, though it still
seems annoying to have
to type the namespace I'm
working in to every command.
CASLYN: Well, you're in luck.
If you're going
to be working out
of the same namespace
for a while,
there's a way to set
kubectl to automatically use
that namespace for all
subsequent kubectl commands.
To do that, you would use
kubectl config set-context.
CARTER: Now that sounds handy.
CASLYN: So I think that's
about it for the basics.
You should have just
about everything
you need to know to
understand namespaces in case
you see them in the workplace.
CARTER: I think so.
Let me see if I've
got this right.
A namespace is a
virtual cluster that
lets multiple groups of
users share a cluster.
Each one has its own resources,
policies, and constraints,
meaning only people or
objects in my namespace
will see my pilot services,
and other Kubernetes objects.
Also, I can define rules for
who can do what in my namespace,
and I can enforce
how many resources
can be consumed by
objects in my namespace
using resource
limits and quotas.
CASLYN: Exactly.
Namespaces are a very
useful tool for everything
you just mentioned and more.
CARTER: Wow, many
thanks to Caslyn
for sharing knowledge
about namespaces.
For more information about
how, when, and why to use them,
please check out the
documentation link below.